oh my god
oh my god this is Sonic the Hedgehog
trailer is out and apparently they like
redid the whole design and they fix it
so this movie is automatically going to
be amazing automatically great I love it
we're gonna be shooting a reaction for
the first episode of the mandalorian
right after we get this uploaded so do
keep a lookout for that porfavor let's
just hop on into this now shall we
[Music]
[Music]
anomaly detected
I just thought you might like a latte
with steamed Austrian goat
of course I Wow
[Music]
[Music]
the tech - Pikachu vibe sir
while we're all over the world yeah
[Music]
so you're supposed to be Tom's best
friend that he won't shut up about we
redid Sonic yeah so I went into this
pretty cynical I went into this thinking
I'm sure the design will look better
it'll it'll be more appeasing to fans
and whatnot but I'm sure the movies
still gonna like look like crap
literally when we saw the last trailer
which I believe Paramount has set to
private remember when I saw that trailer
I was like sure the design and looks off
and whatever but really it's just a
movie that doesn't look good to me
I thought just overall this trailer was
significantly better this at least sold
me on this will probably deliver on just
being a really good laid back time that
we'll probably have just a whole lot of
fun I don't know how special this looks
I'm sure this will be special for real
fans of Sonic I do appreciate the design
and and kudos to the VFX artists for
having to turn this around so this is
pretty fast honestly like the amount of
time it takes to do this they turned it
around really quick and it does look
great I just thought the trailer was
generally funnier yeah and I was more
swept up in the spectacle of all the
speedforce
sonic does explore here like that and
all the visuals looked like dynamite I
did think sonic look pretty you blended
in with the world really well and it
does look really funny I don't know how
great this is gonna be I did get some
detective Pikachu vibes which I did
overall enjoy and Jim Carrey does look
really funny here yeah whereas the first
trailer was like I feel like Jim Carrey
was trying really hard even though a lot
of people really loved him in there I
was still like it feels like he's trying
to do old Jim Carrey and then here this
felt a little bit more natural to me
yeah I went into this thing and I was
gonna like the design more but the movie
is still gonna look awful and then now I
find myself more sold on the actual
movie so yeah good good for them it's
good trailer regardless it's a really
they they did a great job on recovery on
the trailer yeah
I don't know if this'll be great but it
definitely does look more palatable and
like it has more potential to actually
be like you said just a fun you know
video game adaptation movie maybe not
the best one but hey you know for Sonic
especially for what Sonic is I feel like
just a plucky fun movie would be
probably the right flavor Jim Carrey
especially in this trailer I feel like
there's let him breathe more they picked
more moments that showcase I mean he
does seem like he's going back to his
classic Jim Carrey energy for the height
of this movie and also noticing like you
know and I think some of the acting
makes more sense in this trailer like
some James Marsden's bigger reactions to
things you know like the fantasy it was
always a fantasy but there's something
yeah they're just coalesce is a bit
better about this trailer I don't know
again ultimately if it's gonna be like a
quality film or a quality comedy but it
definitely doesn't look as strange and
bad as the first yeah so I you know it's
like I have a lot more faith in it I
have more hope because what this trailer
especially did was it saw me on on the
main three things I think you need to be
sold on especially if you have any you
know knowledge of Sonic at all even in
the slightest which is you gotta sell
you on the sonic look the sonic
character which he does seem pretty
appealing he does seem charming and
funny and similar to the cartoon and you
gotta sell us on dr. Robotnik the
protagonist and the antagonist you gotta
sell us on and they look like the
highlights of the film and you gotta saw
some of the visuals of what sonic is
doing so I feel like all the main things
they honed in on the main things they
focused on I thought they did a really
great job with it because I remember
with the first one you know you see
we've seen a lot of speed capabilities
and stuff lately especially in cinema
with flash and Quicksilver and then I'm
even watching the flash show so I'm
really used to that and now with the
amount of location exploration they were
doing it really gave something different
to me it kind of reminded me of I forget
what they're called like though the
ultimate fatalities and injustice when
flash is like haha you know take you
back to the dinosaur age like the amount
of traveling they're doing I feel like
the scope of it is what's gonna really
help set it apart because you know
Quicksilver and flash they're usually
and I think
okay to reference it especially because
referencing the flash here they're kind
of just in certain locations and they're
doing that ability but to go around the
world and like have these epic chase
sequences where they're going through
the rings that take you to different
parts that would lend itself to a unique
type of speedforce visual design mm-hmm
well I do like to that and I don't know
how much they're gonna use it but I
thought it was neat that this trailer
started out with like the actual Sonic
the Hedgehog world and then he
transports to earth through a ring and
so I don't know how much we're gonna see
him that but I know that in the first
trailer there were also clips from other
parts of what appeared to be that land
yeah dr. Robotnik in his full classic
video game look exactly so I do hope
that there's a certain amount of jumping
back and forth for that because that's
the stuff that looked the most unique is
sort of like the use of all the
specifically Sonic things and the earth
elements look kind of generic you know
kind of like a lot of other movies yeah
yeah I mean I'm not playing I'm sitting
my expectations right at I'm going to
enjoy this and it's going to be fun yeah
that's all I wanted I really do hope
though because to do those readers like
it's not cheap so and the fact that this
trailer has blown up on the end like
we're one of the last people to do a
reaction to this this came out of 3a and
our time at a party you got to make sure
you're gonna recoup that box-office and
all the amount of like reshoot or
redesign you have to do the time or
recouping and then I'm looking at the
trailer like this trailer has blown up
on the internet exceptionally more likes
than dislikes yeah which was the
antithesis so the fact that this trailer
is now trending is usually I'm like
sometimes they do a second trailer for
movies and they do look better with a
second trailer but it doesn't do much to
help win over audiences and I feel like
this could be that rare case that has
won over the people who were naysayers
and negative to the to the first trailer
so yeah I have faith that this could
actually deliver oh yeah alright guys
well did you prefer this sonic trailer
you like it overall comment below you
guys can subscribe to the real rejects
please click that notification bell so
you notify remember got a youtube video
up to check us out on patreon where we
do weekly Q&A Steve show reaction stream
along several shows that have reaction
highlights include that we edit
ourselves and he does music video
reactions weekly I'd like to end this
with a page from the day shout out to a
man named Daniel Gallagher
now I talked about Daniel Gallacher a
lot or Scottish friend but one thing the
ladies might not know about Daniel is
that he is a speed force in the bedroom
every time he goes to lay bed with a
lady all right we do in this he does if
he goes in a speed force zone yes she
does all the positions in his mind in
his zone his world it's like five
seconds and then right away when he's
done the girls go are we gonna and then
suddenly all the sensations in am at
once because he got all those pleasure
points done in the speedforce time zone
Daniel is fast and ready to satisfy it
shout out complete